seeing declines in our cases but the
trend is currently very stable overall
and the trend is not very concerning to
the state team at this time
the state's positivity rate over the
last 14 days is now at 4.2 percent
but nevada's covet 19 response director
caleb cage says
just because we're under the 5 percent
mark doesn't mean we are home free
while we are hopeful that the
consequences are lower because of
the introduction of the tool of the
vaccine it's extremely important to
remember
that the vaccine is only one of the
tools that we have
that we have the statewide mask mandate
that the governor has kept in place even
after may 1st
that means wear your mask continue to
maintain your distance and wash your
hands often
today over at the health district all
clinical services including covet 19
vaccines
were canceled due to a leak of their
water boiler while repairs are underway
the district encouraged those to head
over to both the cashman center
and convention center to fulfill their
appointments a process many said was
quick
and painless there's no waiting at all i
walked right through they got me
all the way through i sat down i got the
shot i barely felt it
and many people we spoke to at the
convention center believe that now as
people are getting their second doses
that the process has become easier the
second time around is a lot faster in
and out the first time we had it
that wait was a little bit longer it's
more organization that's what that's
what's making the difference i think
they're getting better and better are
moving
doing it faster
and starting monday all nevadans 16 and
up will be eligible to get their
vaccination
now 32.4 percent of the population that
is 16 and up
have already initiated vaccinations
that's very good news
reporting live at the convention center
madison kimbrough 8 news now